from its old phone booths to its double
decker buses bright red is a color we
associate with the city of London
far less well-known are 13 little green
shacks that dot the British capital
together they're part of a very
exclusive club that's been part of
London life for well over a century
Jonathan Vigliotti tells us who gets to
go inside London's distinctive green
cabman's shelters no bigger than
horse-drawn carriages are kind of like
America's version of a route six diner
tired travelers line up at the door but
here only those with the knowledge can
gain access inside that makes people
like Kate Simmons the unlikely bouncer
of her shelter on Russell Square hey
we've got smelly pay but not smelly
because he smells many because he's
always got aftershave on drivers
nicknames are as established as the
history of these huts first built in the
1870s for London's black cab drivers the
men and women who've memorized every
single crooked road in the city they
were established in the days of horse
and carriage as a way to keep drivers
out of pubs and on the roads today they
also help keep them sane explains cabbie
Mick Smith they are tight quarters what
is it that keeps you coming back here
instead of somewhere was a little bit
more space oh well they are a shelter
and it's you know show not just from the
weather the elements but from the
madding crowds outside the shelters have
become so well-known for their cheap
eats they now serve the public through
the window Tracy Edwards Hut on Warwick
Avenue is a regular haunt for some local
famous faces like musician Paul Weller
and some visitors from out of town
window how does he take his sandwich the
current US ambassador Woody Johnson has
also been allowed inside we've been
talking about icons this morning and
there's Parliament there's Big Ben
there's obviously the bright red phone
booth
Kaplan shelters green-green Traci's
little building is known for her
breakfast staple the bacon sandwich oh
yeah go for it is right so there's
butter and just bacon yeah there used to
be 61 shelters in this city but now only
twelve are in business as the city's
black cabs compete with uber and other
car services for space on the road cab
drivers and their tiny green shelters
are kind of like the salt and pepper of
London life wit to season any
conversation and always around at least
for now for CBS this morning Saturday
Jonathan Vigliotti London for some
reason I'm hungry for one of those
butter and bacon stays it bad that the
butter and bacon sandwich sounded really
good I love those little green places I
hope they don't disappear